son 40 años atrás
que vamos a ver esta historia de esa
foto
en donde pasaba largos veranos en la
hacienda de mi abuelo una hacienda
maravillosa que se llamaba bella vista
por la maravillosa
tierra que tenía unos terrenos
maravillosos gigantes llenos de
naturaleza llenos de vida nosotros
vivíamos en esta hacienda pasamos casi
todos nuestros veranos allí
y lo más lindo era que nosotros
lográbamos conectarnos con nuestra
tierra una tierra que nos traía nuestros
alimentos que nos traía esa nutrición
tan linda con es hecha vamos con mi
abuelo las papas que íbamos a cocinar
más tarde con nuestro logro en esa olla
de barro en esa olla que nos conectaba
también con la tierra con la
alimentación con la familia una historia
maravillosa y una infancia que realmente
nos trajo nos trajo tantos recuerdos a
mí ya toda mi familia
ese abuelo que tenemos que teníamos pues
un abuelo sabio un viejo maravilloso que
nos acompañaba que él mismo con sus
manos sembraba ese arado nos enseñaba
cada plantita cada semilla tenía un
conocimiento que realmente muy pocas
personas que conocido lo han tenido y
nos transmitió todo ese amor a la
naturaleza ese amor por cada una de las
plantitas que sembraba vamos esa gente
que ustedes ven ahí esa gente que creía
con nosotros eran en nuestra parte de la
familia gente que araba la tierra con
nosotros jugaba con nosotros nos echaba
y que eran realmente esos campesinos
hermosos que vivían junto a nosotros
han pasado casi 40 años de esa época
maravillosa y nos hemos dado cuenta que
cada vez nos desconectamos más de la
alimentación vemos hoy por hoy niños que
no saben cómo crece un brócoli o se
sorprenden de alguna manera cuando ven
que por ejemplo una zanahoria no nace
del bien en una funda plástica sino que
realmente viene de la tierra también nos
comenzamos a dar cuenta de que tenemos y
otros productos maravillosos y como la
remolacha por ejemplo que nosotros un
chiquito se conecta el bebé debe sembrar
debe crecer y comemos absolutamente
todas las partes de su fruto no
solamente la remolacha en sí y sus hojas
y vemos que cada parte de esta magia de
la tierra nos la podemos llevar a
nuestro cuerpo y esa gente esa gente que
de alguna manera en un momento trabajaba
con nosotros la tierra hoy ha tenido que
emigrar a las ciudades porque ha migrado
a las ciudades porque ya no es
sostenible vivir como de su tierra se
dan cuenta de que las cosas que ellos
sembraban ya no son necesarias que la
gente cada vez
viven más rápido come comida procesada
no se conecta con los alimentos entonces
se han dado cuenta que emigrar a la
ciudad ha sido la mejor opción
el ecuador es un país maravilloso que
tiene todos los nutrientes tiene el
clima perfecto tiene la ubicación
perfecta tiene todas las bondades para
poder tener una cantidad de super
alimentos que se han ido perdiendo en el
tiempo y hoy queremos empezar a
rescatarlos como por ejemplo la quinua
cuantos de nosotros no conocemos la
quina porque la conocemos por la sopita
que nos hacía nuestra abuela pero alguna
vez nos hemos puesto a pensar cuántos
nutrientes tiene este maravilloso
superalimento o tal vez un amaranto que
también tiene tantos beneficios en sí
como la quinoa misma yo me acuerdo que
en la casa de mi mamá teníamos esta
orilla que hoy por hoy la llaman
internacionalmente golden bear y le dan
un nombre bien rimbombante para nosotros
era una mala hierba que creía en la
crecía en la casa y realmente no le
hacíamos ni caso
esta orilla es una fuente de
antioxidantes tan maravillosa que hoy
por hoy la gente comienza a demandarla
desde afuera y hoy le empezamos a
sembrar porque ya se ha perdido incluso
los cultivos que son nativos
estamos nosotros siendo parte también de
una campaña de rescate de alimentos de
rescate de esas semillas ancestrales por
ejemplo una de ellas es el poroto
también tenemos el protón es un árbol
super generoso que nos da una especie de
frijol que se da una vez al año y es una
fuente de proteína maravillosa
anteriormente ancestralmente lo usaban
incluso para nuestra alimentación y
luego poco a poco para darle de comer al
ganado y se ha ido perdiendo en el
tiempo que fuente tan maravillosa de
proteína estamos perdiendo ahí que nos
servía de tanta manera para podernos
nutrir tenemos el cacao un cacao que es
otra semilla ancestral que tenemos aquí
en el ecuador y porque la empezamos a
rescatar porque internacionalmente
comienza a ser demandada y eso hace que
de alguna manera comenzamos a ver todos
los valores que tienen nutricionales
antioxidantes todo lo que tiene para
darnos nuestro organismo también tenemos
unos frutos secos como el macambo por
ejemplo el maca lo que es considerado un
cacao blanco este se da en la amazonía y
tiene también fibra tiene proteína cosas
que realmente nosotros hemos estado
acostumbrados a traer frutos secos y no
a consumir los que tenemos aquí en el
ecuador
un ejemplo adicional el sacha inchi una
fuente de omega 3 6
más amplia incluso que cualquier pescado
azul lo tenemos nosotros aquí en nuestra
amazonía y realmente hemos empezado
recién a conocer a poder utilizarlo ya
poder sembrar lo de nuevo les voy a
hablar un poquito también de la moringa
si bien la moringa no es una planta
ecuatoriana es una planta originaria de
la india que se utilizaba en la en el
áfrica para la desnutrición infantil
pero por qué es tan importante porque
tiene más calcio que la leche más
proteína que el yogur tiene más hierro
que una espinaca más vitamina c que una
naranja vitamina a que una zanahoria es
en sí un superalimento que si se consume
y de alguna manera empezamos a incluir
en nuestra alimentación va a sufrir
muchísimo de esas deficiencias que
tenemos nutricional hoy por hoy
pero porque les hablo de todo esto y por
qué es tan importante este tema de la
alimentación y estos productos porque la
fao nos dice que la industria ganadera
nos genera tanto pero tanto co2 o tanto
efecto invernadero que de alguna manera
en el tiempo no va a ser sostenible
entonces qué tenemos que hacer volver a
migrar a estos alimentos a esta fuente
de nutrientes impresionante que nos
comienza a dar toda esta alimentación
que se ha perdido y que tenemos que
comenzar a rescatar entonces cuál es la
solución a todo esto empezar a buscar
dejar esos monocultivos comenzar a hacer
una agricultura artesanal una
permacultura comenzar a buscar esos
sembríos orgánicos y comenzar a
conectarnos con la alimentación de nuevo
para dejar todos los pesticidas dejar
toda la parte que nos hace consumir de
manera masiva y volver a darles de sus
artesanos y a esos campesinos la razón
para que puedan volver a sus tierras
debemos generar espacios que reúnan al
productor y al consumidor de nuevo
nosotros tenemos ya un espacio que más
de cuatro años hemos venido cultivando
con mi hermana un lugar en el que
queremos que justamente el consumidor y
el productor se vuelvan a encontrar
quitemos los intermediarios demos la
oportunidad a es más de nosotros tenemos
más de 600 pequeños emprendimientos que
generan ahí y que son visibles con su
producto para que para que la gente
pueda volver a valorar lo que es este
producto verdadero este producto natural
este producto completamente conectado
con la tierra que es lo que va a lograr
esto va a lograr que nosotros podamos
apoyarles a los campesinos y ellos
puedan volver a sus tierras queremos que
vuelvan y que se conecten nuevamente con
sus antepasados conecten con sus
familias que comiencen a hacer
inspiración para otras comunidades y que
de alguna manera volvamos a conectarnos
pero qué pasa mucha gente me dice
está bien podemos hacer todo esto de
alguna manera eso también lo pueden
hacer las empresas puede apoyarnos
incluso el gobierno pero qué puedo hacer
desde mi espacio cuál es el cambio que
yo puedo generar hoy yo digo el cambio
está en cada decisión que tomamos cuando
vamos al supermercado llevamos no nos
llevamos una funda de plástico cómo
hacemos ese consumo consciente de alguna
manera cómo nos volvemos a conectar con
ese consumo responsable ese consumo
que nos puede ayudar a volver a volver a
nuestro centro y a volver a nuestra
alimentación consciente que les puedo
dar de ejemplos el tema de que el
consumo a granel podemos volver a
consumir a granel cuántas veces
consumimos o compramos más allá de lo
que necesitamos como ya bien en envases
empacados o preempacados compramos lo
que existe y cuánto de eso no se
convierte en un desperdicio entonces
cambiemos esa cultura que teníamos y ese
cambio que hoy por hoy les invito a que
tengamos para que para que consumamos lo
que necesitamos para que volvamos a
conectarnos con esos hábitos y esos
patrones alimenticios que sean con
desconectado en el claro del tiempo
una cosa que ya no y ni siquiera es una
invitación si no es una obligación
tenemos que empezar a reciclar si no
dividimos nuestra basura si por lo menos
no podemos a veces evitar el consumirla
porque está en todo lado pero por lo
menos tengamos que hacernos cargo de esa
basura como las separamos como la
utilizamos como la reutilizamos ya
muchas veces no podemos separar la o no
hay un lugar cerca que tenemos que
buscarlos pero aún así démosle una
segunda vida a todos estos plásticos a
la ropa misma hay tantas cosas creativas
que podemos hacer con nuestros mismos
niños como por ejemplo enseñarles a
tener su propio huerto yo con mi
chiquito empezamos ya a sembrar nuestros
propios alimentos que él se conecte con
ellos que sepa de dónde viene cada una
de esas plantitas y que de alguna manera
cuando nos pidan la comida él sepa qué
es lo que está pidiendo y sepa de dónde
vino y una cosa también súper importante
que yo también quisiera que ya la
empecemos a cambiar es el hecho de poder
hacernos cargo de nuestros residuos que
mejor empezar a compostar en casa
una de las cosas más difíciles de hoy
por hoy de reciclar es todo lo que son
desperdicios orgánicos porque no
empezamos a compostar en casa hagámonos
cargo de esa basura y utilicemos la y
démosle una vida para que se te
descomponga ahí mismo y nos genere un
abono para que para esa misma tierra
para esa tierra que nuestros niños están
sembrando que están utilizando y
devolvamos de la tierra toda esa
conexión o todo eso que hemos perdido
conectamos con cada uno de nuestros
alimentos y con con todo lo que la
tierra tiene para darnos a nosotros una
cosa que yo también hoy por hoy creo que
es súper importante hacer es darles
también esa oportunidad a los niños
ellos son los que vienen a generar el
cambio no sabemos si nosotros vamos a
estar aquí pero son ellos los que tienen
que aprender a conectarse de nuevo con
la tierra así como yo me conecté 40 años
atrás con todo lo que mi abuelo tenía
para enseñar enseñamos a nuestros niños
que es de esta alimentación consciente
cómo vienen los alimentos cómo se
cosechan cómo se consumen y sobre todo
obviamente cómo se come
nos quedan 12 años para saldar un
planeta de una catástrofe climática nos
dice la onu es decir en el 2030 vamos a
tener un momento muy clave para nosotros
de saber qué es lo que va a pasar por el
mundo todo eso depende de cuáles
acciones tomemos hoy que es lo que hoy
voy a hacer para que en el 2030 no haya
esta catástrofe cuál decisión voy a
hacer en cada cambio que voy a hacer en
mi vida para que eso no pueda pasar
porque no impresiona tanto porque esta
foto que les muestro es la foto de mi
chiquito él se está graduando del
colegio recién en el 2035 es decir cinco
años después de esa fecha tan
impresionante que nos ponen adelante
él es el que me inspira a mí hacer el
cambio a generar conciencia al hacer
cada cada decisión que tome una decisión
importante que valga la pena
él me inspira a mí quisiera saber quién
es inspira ustedes muchas gracias